[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à tours pour
vous faire visiter quelques endroits où
on peut admirer graffiti et street art
dans l'agglomération et puis un artiste
local nous conduira sur un de ses
terrains de jeu
un lieu un petit peu plus reculée un
tour le graffiti s'épanouit en partie
sous les ponts sous l'autoroute a10 côté
sainte radegonde un mur est
régulièrement fréquenté par les
graffeurs en témoigne cette référence à
l'actualité récente outre-atlantique en
rouge
icloud bref je ne peux plus respirer
phrase prononcée par djordje floyd tué
par un policier à minneapolis
depuis quelques années l'un des
principaux points de ralliement est
aussi selon mur d'enceinte des casernes
beaumont chauveau quartier maryse bastié
plusieurs réunions officielles ils y ont
eu lieu et de manière plus isolé les
graffeurs continue de fréquenter
l'endroit pour le plaisir des yeux des
riverains très sympa justement les gens
ils peuvent s'exprimer avec leurs leur
art et le mur soit mis à leur
disposition c'est très très bien le quel
est votre préféré
maryse bastié en premier et ensuite
franchement le pire visage de l'enfant
basculer il est beau c'est un visage de
rêve
des fois je les voyais je les regarde
quoi je t'aimerai chapeau c'est bien
donc si je leur demande aussi pour
reconnaître qui a fait quoi les endroits
où c'est qu'ils signent justement donc
avoir des signatures lucas on a laissé
un peu partout il compte parmi les
graffeurs actifs de l'agglomération
outre les terrains légaux il affectionne
aussi les endroits laissés à l'abandon
[Musique]
ici faux finis tes sens pour moi urbain
du coup
puis des ambiances différentes avec la
nature qui vient reprendre le dessus
j'obtiens des des photos avec des murs
wierre qu'elle choisit en fonction de
ses pattes des mousses qui pousse dessus
ou la luminosité tout c'est d'un gros
c'est ce qui sort de ma tête et
j'ai des réflexes pense de défunts que
j'ai depuis que cheval en plus déçus
quand j'étais petit avait une série de
boîtes d'allumettes c'était clame up et
j'avais je devais avoir 6 ans comme ça
et j'en avait piqué une à mon père pour
recopier les grappes qui était dessus
il commençait aussi un peu en ont comme
ça copier puis après mélanger tout ce
que mélanger toutes mes références
personnages ou lettrage graffiti légal
ou sauvages également organisateur de
soirée rap et peinture avec d'autres
lucas contribuer à la vitalité de la
scène tourangelle
[Musique]
nous retrouvons ici à saint pierre des
corps aux ateliers de la morinerie un
autre lieu de graffitis et de street art
sur l'agglomération tourangelle
nous sommes toujours avec luca luca
graffiti street art est ce qu'il ya une
différence est ce que tu en fais une
différence pour moi le street art s'est
plus orienté tout ce qui va être pochoir
tout ce qui va être collage par exemple
le graffiti pour moi ça va être quelque
chose de plus classique avec des
lettrages toute la culture geek toute la
culture issus du hip hop on fait avec
les big boys tout ça tout ce qui va avec
le rap et toi tu revendiques aussi le
côté entre guillemets vandalisme ça
attire parce que c'est l'adrénaline qui
rompt qui rentre en compte et c'est une
pratique ouais c'est plus sauvages du
coup il ya ce petit ce petit côté
interdit qui est peut-être attirant moi
je pense que le graphite y est ça doit
rester dans la rue c'est ça qui est
intéressant ici c'est que la rue à
l'offre
diversité de supports
tu as des stores ta d'état les murs
enfin un peu de tout tu peux monter en
hauteur aussi si tu veux tendre un peu
plus visible et tout ça
ici on est à côté du plus grand
technicentre de france saint pierre des
corps et s'était que tout ce qui est
ferroviaire attire graffiti tous les
graffeurs donc du coup c'est un peu
c'est un peu un lieu de pèlerinage pour
tous ceux qui aiment parle qu'est ce qui
motive alors qu'il ya des risques
on va justement c'est un peu cette prise
de risques côté j'élabore mon plan pour
je me donne du mal à les faire quelque
chose pour la récompense c'est quand tu
passes le lendemain devant et que tu te
dis bon ma voix la personne ne sait qui
a fait ça c'est là et les gens le voient
toi tu le vois merci lucas et puis
demain on verra on rencontrera un
graffeur qui s'est lui spécialisé dans
l'exploration urbaine
rendez vous demain